le contrôle technique des véhicules
motorisés à deux roues ou trois roues
sera-t-il finalement mis en place depuis
le 31 octobre 2022 et le Conseil d'État
qui le rendait obligatoire aucune date
d'entrée en vigueur n'est encore connue
pas de quoi crier victoire du côté des
motards qui restent mobilisés contre
cette mesure une nouvelle mobilisation
nationale était organisée le week-end
dernier par la Fédération Française des
Motards en Colère la Turquie
occupez-vous des routes et on s'occupe
de nos motos le slogan est clair pour la
Fédération Française des Motards en
Colère le contrôle technique des deux
roues ça ne passe toujours pas
plusieurs centaines de manifestants se
sont réunis à Tours ont répondu présent
les motards d'Indre-et-Loire mais aussi
de la Sarthe du Loir-et-Cher et de la
Vienne un jeune quand il passe son
permis un motard il est censé connaître
sa moto il est censé savoir si c'est
plaquettes sont usées si la chaîne
Alizée le pneu qui en bon état une
voiture on le fait pas un motard il est
complètement responsable il va faire son
contrôle beaucoup plus loin alors le
contrôle technique c'est un non-sens
pour les manifestants eux qui annoncent
que 0,3% des accidents des deux roues
ont pour cause un défaut technique camp
près d'un tiers sont liés à l'état des
infrastructures il va à tout prix mettre
ce contrôle technique en place pourquoi
parce qu'en fin de compte voilà il
s'aperçoivent qu'il y a de plus en plus
de motards et qui a vraiment du fric à
se faire sur le dos des motards sauf que
depuis 10 ans le nombre de motards ne
cesse d'augmenter
et l'accident des deux roues motorisés
ne cesse de baisser donc trouver
l'erreur après le centre ville de Tours
direction Saint-Pierre-des-Corps
peinture à la main ils ont surligné les
irrégularités des routes et donc les
dangers potentiels une action pour
montrer les chantiers à faire en
priorité selon eux avant d'attaquer
celui du contrôle technique